sta andando L'unica cosa è che ho un
problema di timidezza Quindi ti chiedo
se per un minuto fai tipo due passi
Che bello fare lo youtuber a 10 anni e
avere problemi di timidezza Bella a
tutti ragazzi benvenuti Allora vi spiego
questa è una cosa molto Innanzitutto vi
sto portando un Gameplay Siete contenti
eh Vi sto portando Hogwarts Legacy Siete
contenti per due Insomma immagino
anch'io Salve chiedo scusa ragazzi se il
tono di voce che utilizzerò per questo
Gameplay sarà un po' più basso del
solito dei miei Gameplay normali ma
siamo in una sala dove c'è un eco
pazzesco e c'è un sacco di gente quindi
non vorrei fare Bella a tutti ragazzi un
intero secondo Quindi questo è il motivo
Ah vi faccio il personaggio sto male ci
siamo comunque poteva andare peggio dai
un po' da lontano mi somiglia voce uno
voce due Sono impaziente di andare Ciao
Martina
Beh ragazzi siamo abbiamo siamo Va beh
Avete capito No Salve Posso parlare fa
niente Non importa se Peppe verde sono
sempre dei pezzi No scherzo sono libero
fuori da Hogwarts ma sto male Ragazzi
allora vediamo se riesco quindi posso
volare dove voglio
il mio sogno No vi prego mettete una
scopa volante Anche a Milano è
fighissima sta roba quindi io posso
girarmi Hogwarts così
no raga Sono un bambino sono diventato
un bambino alle giostre posso passare in
mezzo alle cose Vediamo se sbatto
No ragazzi No ragazzi Oddio
per un niente No ragazzi non avete
capito Cioè non posso fare l'esaltato
perché devo tenere un tono di voce basso
che qua c'è un sacco di gente ma Dio mio
Ma io faccio il tempo solo a fare questo
che roba
Cosa sto vedendo cioè la mia infanzia
raga È incredibile Io sono la vostra ma
questa è la mia Ah c'è sempre verde
Grifondoro non potreste non so
picchiarvi visto che siete sempreverde
che questo rumore
Grazie grazie grazie
faccio del mio meglio
andiamo via è un po' come quando la
gente vi dice no mi hai salvato la vita
con i tuoi video
Allora vediamo se riesco a raggiungere
il cortile interno e sto sbattendo
contro muri ma è come sapete tutti La
patente l'ho presa da omino Scusate
ragazzi
cos'è che sta succedendo
provengono
vedrai che spazzare il cortile è
un'esperienza più produttiva io me ne
vado io faccio uno spazzare in camera
questa sta facendo la cacca così facendo
Ah no stai guardando per terra giochi a
biglie posso anche io
scherzavo gioca piglia da sola Dov'è lo
zio che devo Eccoci qua Luca devo
parlare con te bravo
ad altri duellanti E chi resiste fino
alla fine Ah devo prendermi a cazzo
l'ha detto anche lui giustamente
oppure illegale duellare tra di noi
sì ma stai calma stai calma eh
levioso E levioso non leviosò aggancio
bersaglio R3 e mi sposto Let's go
Mannaggia devo usare levioso come faccio
a usare
durante la pungente Eccomi Porca vacca
e questa è letteralmente sto spaccando
Ma no vabbè Non penso si possa fare
questa cosa ad Hogwarts sto attaccando
più il mio compagno che l'altro Però
vabbè
a storia si chiama Oh aspetta che ti
racconto questa storia la storia ok Non
si può andare vicino a tirargli una
pedata in faccia no Peccato Ho vinto lo
stesso sono quasi morto ma ne è valsa la
pena
Allora Ah vedi che adesso mi metto anche
la mira
No vabbè ragazzi Ma quante ne ho lì di
spell
in cui a girarvi è venite a fare
Effettivamente potevo anche non spararti
in faccia è stato molto sgarbato scusi
c'è un cervo
Porca Vacca c'è gente Oddio
ma li posso sniperare
Oddio cosa si sta guardando in giro non
ha capito cosa sta succedendo non lo
posso sniperare Peccato perché asilo
posso stendere
non pensavo di attirarti subito però uno
lo sniperato Raga mi dispiace no
Ho sbagliato No raga sto facendo un
casino facendo un casino eh Non sono non
so ballare Non so ballare non so
dell'aria non l'ho ancora fatto i
tutorial Scusatemi non ho fatto i
tutorial raga State mi sono parato
benissimo Non so come ho fatto
ogni tanto mi pare Sperando che qualcuno
mi attacchi per fare la figura del figo
che sa giocare ma in realtà non so
giocare ok
Allora aspetta che Madonna sono
bravissima e daje fuoco
Eh sì
stai attenzione zio posso fargli un
Wingardium ma solo per curiosità
Sì e poi questo madonna eh Non volevo
scassare anche il ponte ragazzi L'ho
fatto per sbaglio giuro posso riparare
il ponte e l'ho scassato io Scusatemi
non so come farla riparare
No oddio oddio come ho fatto ho tradito
non so come ho fatto mi sono salvato Che
culo
Let's go my boys Ma perché io sono nato
per questo sono solo nato nell'universo
sbagliato dove la magia non esiste però
so che in un universo parallelo c'è un
Favij che sta utilizzando le magie e lo
invidio un sacco Io lo so bene Te ne
abbia dei Bracconieri
cosa
sono
hai lunga rospinato Sarà mica Ah c'è una
competizione da draghi io punto sul
verde tipo no Lungaro spinato E l'altro
li conosco a memoria Adesso sono io ho
già studiato io non c'è bisogno che vada
Hogwarts lo so già a casa
del fatto che tutti gli occhi sono sul
combattimento per ispezionare in giro ma
con discrezione nessuno deve accorgersi
di te ok
con discrezione non io che sto spaccando
il culo a un Bracconiere Subito Vabbè
vabbè
Madonna
ragazzi sono fortissimo cioè io ne so
attacchi Minchia non l'avrei mai detto
Cosa vuol dire che uno Oddio sì vabbè
ciao Ci avevo la ulti in canna e non lo
sapevo scusi non l'avevo vista lei a
saperlo la facevo fuori prima
ho capito come padroneggiare la
bacchetta ragazzi
le mele rubiamo tutto tanto chi se ne
frega
le devi sbloccare tu le cose sto male eh
non ho la minima idea di cosa devo fare
Ah fai finta che il gioco io ok tagliamo
questo pezzo grazie
ho sbloccato questa magica serratura
tutto da solo con skill alohomora
ragazzi alohomora sblocca tutto
istantaneamente cazzate gli hanno
mentito per vent'anni andiamo Sì sì ci
sono Non sono mica stato sei ore a tenta
di sbloccare una serratura Allora
Picchio questi o sgancio il drago
Vicchio questi Va bene Madonna ragazzi
ma quanti cacchio sono non sono troppi
aiuto
e svegliati gioca anche tu no tu di qua
e io posso lanciare le cose addosso la
gente
sto male
E vabbè ma saperlo prima che fosse
scassando tutto muoiono Guarda
Ormai sono skillato raga Sono skillato
Mori non puoi lanciare una vada a
cadabra facciamo prima Vabbè
l'ho fatta ce l'ho fatta Ora sgancio
Porca vacca mi sembra realizzato
qualcuno ti stavano proprio cercando e
hai portato compagnia
sì
scassagli tutto Madonna Che botta
eh vabbè ma quanto sono forte ma
Scusatemi Eh vabbè Ragazzi ma neanche in
God of War incredibile perché sono
veramente no sono morto No non mi sono
curato in tempo Non ho guardato ma
quanto sono forte ragazzi va bene Mi
rifarò Anche perché non sapevo
combattere però me la sono secondo me
poteva andare peggio poteva andare molto
peggio concludo questo video nella
maniera più strana del mondo perché un
video un po' strano il tono io c'ho devo
tenere così purtroppo perché c'è gente
vi ringrazio per aver visto questo video
ci vediamo all'uscita del gioco perché
porte sicuramente il gioco completo e
iscrivetevi al canale lasciate un bel mi
piace e noi come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo video alohomora non serve un
cavo si imparano sempre le cose nei